you and joining us with more is ahmad
shaban he is the truck driver
he is the one that put an end to that
chase blocking the fleeing vehicles path
ahmad thank you for being with us
look thank you now you know the danger
that you were facing
you saw what was happening how did you
know that that car
needed to be stopped and and did it take
a lot of thought or was it just
instinctive for you well they uh
i saw them uh chasing him about five
blocks
before where i hit him and uh
i was talking to my friend on the phone
i was telling him hey there's a car
being
uh chased by like 40 50 cops and he was
like yeah that guy's a murderer so i'm
like oh no way and then
i kept going because they already passed
and then maybe about
you know five or seven minutes later
here he comes again but from
behind me and i was looking in my uh
right rear view mirror and i was
watching him coming
uh through the gas station and then i i
had a red light at this minute and then
i just had to you know pick my truck a
little bit ahead
and just to see which direction he was
going to turn into which is right
uh or left and then he did him he took a
left so
i my intention really was to block the
whole entire intersection my truck is
that long
but uh by the time my truck reacted and
he gunned his truck and
i got my truck and then we just slammed
into each other so
yeah are you gonna is there a gofundme
page to help repay
repair the damage of your truck i mean
you certainly deserve that for
your heroism is there anything up there
or anything
yeah i believe my wife set it up under
ahmed shaban the truck driver that
stopped
the police chase well we're going to
find it i'm going to put it up on
my website hannity.com and i'd like to
donate it myself
a lot of people don't want to get
involved the mod you did it
instinctively
you knew it was dangerous you did it
anyway that defines
heroism and courage and thank you for
what you did